all right this one is pretty crazy this
is in belgium this [ __ ] is crazy yeah
this woman
believes she's having an affair with
this chimpanzee has she ever hooked up
with him no because it's through the
glass
yeah so she's she's loved this she says
that she loves the champ chimpanzee the
chimpanzee loves her and he really does
oh she's crazy
yeah because he's you know i guess with
in the chimpanzee i guess groups if one
kind of
bonds with a human more they kind of get
kicked out of the group so what's
happening with this one
for messing with this [ __ ] so she's not
allowed to go to the zoo anymore and
she's really heartbroken and not
subscribed yeah she's like crying she
has a haircut of a robber
38 year old chimpanzee
yeah do you know batshit crazy you have
to be that you connected with the
chimney there you go for four years over
four years i think i bet you it does
though i bet you it sees her and i bet
you doesn't i bet that [ __ ] does that to
every human no no no particularly this
one chimps
no so this chimpanzee came from a home
too before but then it got crazy so
that's why they went to the zoo
you know
like crazy what do you mean dangerous
yeah dangerous yeah just jim's trying to
[ __ ]
one [ __ ] that had he was like feeding
the chips that's such a horrible story
and then he went you know what dude i
don't like your friend i'm gonna rip her
face off yeah you haven't seen her and
her finger bring it up chin and she's
such a horrible surgery and the doctor
was like we did our best they get he
gave the xanax
they [ __ ] her fingers and they would
[ __ ] all the time yeah this he would
[ __ ]
oh yeah oh the face is so horrible
though i can't show this
click on that this one this so when she
got a surgery the doctor went we tried
her best though you know she she gave it
wine and [ __ ] no this is her friend she
got a face transplant you got jealous
for some reason it was upset at her but
she's gotten she's had it better she
looks identical to the guy hannibal
there you go um i mean that that's
that'll just make your whole life took
her eyes out everything
so i did that your friend is [ __ ] the
chimp that's you know that's so awful
where's her friend but no that's a chimp
doing chimp [ __ ] what do you mean he's
awful that's no
that's that's what they do
this poor lady look ripped our hands and
face off
this is why you shouldn't suck chimps
off
it's so terrible the strength of a
[ __ ] chimp i know and she calls the
cops or i think the friend doesn't they
have the 911 call and she's like get
here now he's ripping her hands off
because jim's go for her face in your
hands and you're dead genitals yeah
bitter it's so sad she's like you didn't
rip her tits off
chimps are [ __ ] savage you did
everything to her that was her before i
guess then she got an oprah that poor
poor woman she did yeah it's horrible
it's so horrific oh okay this was oh
yeah okay i remember this
only because i used to watch it but this
is this way you don't make friends with
chips that's why i don't [ __ ] you yeah
dude yeah well yeah it's jim's doing
[ __ ] her friend was [ __ ] the ch
that's no her friend
the owner was hooking up with the champ
brought the and then the lady was like
oh i want to see the chimp she's like
yeah come over and he was trying to
enjoy his glass of wine he's in a robe
and she had changed her hair she got her
hair done and the chimp
decided i don't like that hair and
sometimes and then she stabbed the chimp
the the owner stabbed the chimp and the
chimp just looked at her
like that and then the cops came shot
that chimp like five times
chimp got shot with a nine millimeter i
think with those like hollow point and
the chimp still climbed up on the
[ __ ] roof
and i was like oh cool
and then was just set and then came back
down and i think ultimately died after
it got shot some more
that's how [ __ ] hard horrific story
and this is why people shouldn't have
you know
200 pounds why do you want to [ __ ]
chill why are you putting the chimp in a
robe and having them sleep in your bed
and sucking them off well that trend
that chimp had already bitten somebody
before that and then that woman died of
cancer it's a terrible story horrific
yeah that don't have pet chimps yeah